2e journée d'audience et les témoignages
sont aussi accablant les uns que les
autres et ils proviennent de sa garde
rapprochée enfin joe dassin on apprend
que le soir de l'élection lorsque la
chaîne fox a déclaré joe biden vainqueur
en arizona le comte franz était divine
doudou diagne était en état d'ébriété dj
center un proche conseiller de deurne
autre chose
il disait on a gagné il nouvelles
élections d'où viennent ces votes il
faut dire qu'on a gagné quiconque est en
désaccord est faible
et pourtant ils étaient nombreux à être
en désaccord à commencer par le
directeur de campagne bien ce type yens
j'ai recommandé au président de dire à
ses partisans que c'était trop tôt pour
donner les résultats dit il et qu'il
fallait dire qu'on était fier de notre
campagne et qu'il fallait attendre les
prochains jours
quand même sa fille ivanka trump avait
des doutes
je n'avais pas de point de vue ferme dit
elle on comptait encore les votes
mais rien à faire dans notre homme se
déclare vainqueur aux petites heures du
matin le 4 novembre et se
frotter
les accusations de fraudes électorales
étaient non fondées affirme l'avocat de
renom ben ginsberg
en pennsylvanie dont nous sommes calmes
et 8000 morts avaient voté des
allégations rejetées par le commissaire
électoral de philadelphie qui a subi les
foudres de l'ancien président
après que le président mais ciblés dans
ses tweets dit il
j'ai reçu des menaces elle était
spécifique non seulement contre moi et
contre les membres de ma famille
l'ancien ministre de la justice berben
ne mâche pas ses mots sur l'ancien
locataire de la maison blanche
il était détaché de la réalité dit il et
n'était pas intéressé aux faits mais ses
partisans l'ont cru et ont décidé
d'envahir le capitole le plus bel
opportunisme à faire s'ils pensent
qu'ils vont tricher m baye de ne pouvoir
dit il ils se trompent ça ne va pas
arriver malgré les preuves accablantes
dans notre chambre fustige la commission
d' enquête et l'a comparé à une
véritable charade dans un document de 12
pages il maintient qu'il ya eu fraude
électorale les audiences reprennent
mercredi prochain il ya des boîtes les
galeristes radio-canada washington